[Music]
on today's show
we talk about heavy heavy trauma so this
is not a show for children
we walk alongside a mom working through
unimaginable pain and i peel back the
curtain and let you listen to a
conversation between me and my mentor
as he coaches me on how i should help
this woman stay tuned
[Music]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john deloney show
i hope you are doing well thanks for
choosing this podcast out of the
18 trillion that exists including your
cousins your grand ed piezo podcast
your mother for sure has a podcast that
your mom has a podcast i bet that's even
a thing now
um i'm so glad you're here if you want
to be on the show
give me a shout at 1-844-693-3291
we talk to real people about real
challenges and we walk alongside folks
trying to make the next right decision
and life is messy and hard
1-844-693-3291
mental health relationships parenting
marriage education whatever is going on
in your heart mind give us a shout
or you can go to johndaloni.com show
fill out the form and it goes to kelly
and we will get you on the show
this is a very special episode and i'm
super jazzed about it
for two reasons number one i get to talk
to one of my favorite people in the
world
my practicum supervisor a guy you know
what they told you
in elementary school if you just are in
middle school and high school
you know if you just worked harder you
could be as fast as that guy
or you could lift weights like that guy
be as strong as him it's just because
you're not working hard
and then when you're about a junior
senior in high school you realize that
guy just jumps higher than me
like i could lift all day he's just
faster
i work really really hard and that guy's
just stephen curry he just makes baskets
better than me right
well i didn't realize until i was way
too far down the road that that also
works
academics for brain computational power
i just always
you know told myself the story if you
just studied more or read more
that you would be smart like these other
people and then
i worked with dr gomez
michael gomez that we're gonna talk to
you today as my he's my practicum
supervisor and i realized oh his brain
just
works 10x mine he's just smarter than me
i could study all day and read
everything
nope he's just faster and better than me
at this
so it's one of my great honors so here's
what i'm calling him today this is
exciting
so one of my meta goals for this show
right one of the the regular goals is to
give people practical information they
can take home and use to solve some
of personal challenges that they're
experiencing one of my meta goals is
is to show people what it looks like
to live a healthier well life and so
what i want to do is pull back the
curtain whenever i can on challenging
issues
on regular issues on just normal
everyday life for things that most
people don't get to see
and so we got a a reached we got a call
for today's show from an extraordinary
woman
in texas who experienced some really
outside of the box
trauma and she also has a
child with very particular special needs
and so dr gomez is a friend of mine and
he's a mentor of mine
and he also is a expert child
psychologist
in trauma and in autism
and it just so happens that this
particular call is about how to talk to
a young person with autism about family
trauma
and if you don't have somebody a young
person with autism in your life this
this
this show will still be really important
for you but
i knew hey i need to get some some
deeper insight into this
any good counselor does this any good
therapist does this any good doctor does
this any good
academic does this when they're faced
with something that they want to get
some more information and some more
depth on they don't go to the internet
and read headlines
they call an expert and they ask hard
questions they do this about plumbing
too by the way and how to raise chickens
and how to fix your tire on your car
whatever right
so i wanted to give you good folks a
ringside seat to a conversation between
two professionals
talking about the particulars here and
so we reached out to
dr gomez and i said hey man would you be
mind being on the show and talking me
through this and helping me think
through this
particular question he said absolutely
i'm in and so i'm gonna go straight
to dr michael gomez on the phone
hola muchacho how are you doing hey dr
delany can you hear me okay over there
yeah i can hear you great man
you can just call me john um i'm now i'm
back to being one of your students again
so it's good
okay well you you're in the doctor also
that was maybe the best compliment i've
ever been given
at any point in time so thank you for
that you're welcome man how are you
doing well doing well good to hear from
you good to talk to you hey so before we
go any further
you just got some big fancy new gig tell
me about this
yes um i uh with the profession you see
listen is one that will be starting in
october
um i do a lot of work using with trauma
and autism i
uh was uh lucky enough to get offered a
spot at
uh emma pendleton bradley hospital part
of the lifespan institute in providence
rhode island which is one of
brown university's teaching hospitals so
wonderful place amazing team
stellar nationally and internationally
and just wonderful people working there
and wonderful kids
so if you're a listener this is how two
roads diverge
in a wood
yoda gets a job at a brown teaching
hospital
it's one of the most extraordinary
academic institutions on the planet
the other guy gets a youtube show
that's how we that's how our our paths
converge doctor go
are separated went to our separate ways
so way to go man all right hey i
appreciate you
being willing to talk me through this
situation all right so
here's the here's the story
a couple is married and then they get
divorced
and my understanding and i haven't
talked to this woman yet so i'm just
going through an email that was sent
they get divorced the guy was not a good
husband but a
really excellent father he gets
has a relationship with somebody else
and
um mom and her autistic son
go their separate ways dad is still
super involved in
his autistic son's life he's a great
father
um they are have become friends again
good co-parents
and then rather suddenly he
for reasons unknown to really anybody he
murders his new girlfriend their kid
and then he commits suicide it's all
over the news it's a big thing in the
city with which they live
mom has to tell autistic child
this news and grieve herself
and she has did a great job out of the
gate talking to her son
saying hey dads um your dad has passed
away
man what is the right next step on
talking about how he passed away it's
going to be on the news his friends are
going to ask him about it
and by the way this this child who was
murdered in this situation was close
friends with him
right so now he's got this extra thing
his dad took his own life
and dad also murdered one of his friends
and he's a highly functioning autistic
young man so
man walk me through how we would
navigate that conversation
um both as a 13 year old and then as the
kid grows up
absolutely so a couple of
recommendations for both providers
whether it's a therapist nurse doctor
talking to the parent and for the parent
for mom in this scenario
first i always advise providers like if
you're a counselor
talking to a parent they're gonna want
you to tell the kid this
and we have to very gently tell them we
will
show you how to tell the kid and we'll
walk you through that but we we're not
going to do it ourselves
we'll be in the room if you need us to
we'll be on the phone or on the zoom
camera
and a lot of parents rightly so get
upset they're like well then what am i
paying you for
uh which is a legitimate question and so
the the reason for that is not because
we're trying to avoid it as providers
but
we're not going to be there when the kid
has a nightmare at 2 a.m we're not going
to be there when
you're just having sunday lunch and you
ask the kid if he wants to catch up and
he says why did daddy shoot
you like that's kind of the rhythm it'll
happen and
you know we want someone that the thing
we want to emphasize to parents the
first thing is
you are the best person to talk to them
so
the meta there is the the parents got to
have this conversation gotta
gotta walk through what happened okay
yeah and uh now they can see
just like you said earlier seek support
take expertise practice with the
professional
uh practice with a friend a colleague
and we encourage them to do that
um however we we don't want to kind of
give the
like uh outsource the conversation
basically there you go all right so what
does
mom has mom has already done man she did
it great she
um got beneath eye level she with her
with her with her autistic son she
communicated dad has passed away they
grieved that together it was really
remarkable
and now what's the follow-up
conversation to say hey here's actually
what all went down
yeah i want to also highlight what you
just said which is that that in and of
itself is a huge
victory and strength for mom yeah
because like you said
she is in her own grieving process and
her own confusion and
sadness and anger and fear and she's
putting that
like i'm in this pain but i have to
worry about my little boy here and
so that in itself we want to kind of
touch base on especially as providers
saying
hey you have that conversation yep the
other ones you'll be able to have too if
you got through that one you're going to
get through the
other ones okay and and repetitively
kind of let mom know that
that first one is usually the harder one
even if it may not be the most difficult
one
which i think applies in this case where
your daddy passed away and and that
was hard enough itself now she has to
explain some more of the details
for him but emphasizing that you you've
already done it you already
kind of ripped some of the band-aid off
so you're you know you can do this again
okay we're just going to give you some
extra tools excellent okay
so walk us through the hard stuff here
sure so
a couple of rules that i give caregivers
is um
first less is more okay so and i talk
about micro conversations
um so we don't like this we also do a
similar move when we talk about sex and
sexuality with kids
um we don't we're not a fan of the talk
like the two hour talk that traumatized
most of us
that's right i got to talk i still have
nightmares so
we want like when they're little like
here's the name of your private parts
right
they're growing up why does she have
different private parts well
and those are very short conversations
so a lot of parents will want to kind of
just
blast and rightly so but we want them to
give them information and then check and
so a lot of times when i'm coaching
parents to how to do this
so i want to tell you billy exactly how
your father died
okay okay i told you he passed away and
also um advise parents to give kids as
many options as they can within these
conversations so
the next question would be do you want
to know how he died
okay and nope okay
and then she can ask later maybe like
not necessarily that day but next week
a couple months now the only time i i
kind of show the options is kind of this
scenario where he's gonna see it
so at that with that particular question
i would say your daddy
passed away in a way that's on the news
and you might see it
or might read about it so i really want
to tell you
what happened but even then you can give
options would you like to talk now
would you like to talk on the weekend
would you like to talk tonight
and like we're going to do it it's just
how you get to decide how
and it's almost conscious discipline
like i'm going to give you a set of
options and you get to choose
and but that's letting a child in a
moment that's going to feel really
powerless it's allowing that child to
retain
some shred of autonomy right like some
strategies yeah like i'm holding on to
this
i can control some of this right yes
okay there
um there's a uh i don't know if you're
familiar with the canadian patent oswald
and
his wife wrote about the golden state
killer and she she passed away she died
pretty suddenly
and he was telling an anecdote about in
as a psychologist i thought the teacher
who gave him this advice was brilliant
because this is what we would give
advice to for a family which is she said
don't tell her in the dark give her a
choice like
and so he took her to a park they had a
wonderful morning and then
at lunch time he basically told her what
happened
and and he told her i'm pretty and but
that was unlike this mom that was their
first conversation about that she had
passed away the day before
overnight the cro the kid was at like i
guess an in-laws or something
but giving her options about what she
wanted to hear
what she wanted to hear it how much she
wanted to hear
um and one thing i do especially with
kids who have trauma who have
any kind of uh who are not neurotypical
is i use a one to ten skill
and if they have trouble with numbers we
do like little middle big but i usually
say we're gonna have a tough
conversation billy
so i want to make sure that if if it's
uncomfortable
that i know that but if it's painful
like you feel like something's snapping
i know that
okay so it's a one to ten skill one
means you're totally calm
fine five is a little tough but i'm okay
and ten is i'm gonna break down i'm
gonna start crying or yelling or
shut down and so can we agree that if
you get to seven or eight
that you let me know and that will take
a break and then we'll finish up
at a different time awesome so take your
time and i tell
you you heard me tell that parents when
they're because we're not working like
an er or an icu
and mom has to tell them hey kid died
hit the kid your brother died
i'll say take your time slow it down
you have time even if they may not
objectively have that time
in the moment i want them to go slower
not fast gotcha
and so in the past you and i have talked
extensively
so we're leading up to the moment when
it will say
your daddy died by suicide it's as clear
as it can be
and simple and direct is am i on the
right track there yes and
i always check not not just with kids
with like who have trauma but also kids
with
uh fas autism intellectual disability
our current name for what used to be
called mental retardation
um what do you have you heard that word
before suicide billy what does that mean
what does it mean what do you think and
you and some of the responses are
interesting so like we had a family
where
the kids like oh no it means they killed
themselves and it was like an angel like
wow that's
pretty out the way you learned that and
said anything
anything else it means it's a very
important follow but it means that my
dad's in hell
wait a second let's and which also
signals to me as a psychologist and
now i need to get the chaplain in here
gotcha this is kind of a little bit
above my pay grade no
um so now it's gone theological on us
okay
yeah and what about the follow-up which
would would that be a moment to put a
period at the end of that sentence
and then to circle back and say um
when somebody wait we wouldn't want
somebody to wait until somebody school
pops up and says hey your dad killed
so and so your friend um you'd want to
have that at the same time
or do you want to have some space
between those conversations um
it kind of depends on the kid in the
scenario for this scenario
it sounds like there's an imminent and
uh and so the conversation will have to
probably occur kind of with shorter gaps
okay
um but a gap is good a gap is good and
the gap can be like 10 minutes
to like to basically have the kid down
regulate
so you're at a nine yep let's take a
second let's go play with the
play with our dog and you know come back
in and we'll talk a little bit more
later okay
and give me the verbiage you would you
would pass along
to let somebody know that their dad took
the life of their friend
and uh for for parents i say what
what language do you think they would
understand let's workshop that okay
and i would have them generated um
because especially with kids now
with kind of neurotypical kids who have
trauma i can usually give them language
and the language is based on development
and the very
short version of this which i know you
understand this but just for the
audience
i distinguish kind of between three
levels of the child development within
uh kids like you know young kids to 18.
first one for your kind of toddlers
maybe first grade or second graders
is egocentric which means the definition
is a
plus b equals me and
i know a lot of politicians that still
have that i'm gonna say it's
five-year-olds and some forty-year-old
men but that's not the point
so the next stage up is kind of your
mid to late elementary into junior high
which is concrete a plus b
equals c and one activity one of my
mentors taught me was
right now look around your physical area
just look around really briefly
and audience do this too and if you
don't
see it it is not a causal factor
and so a good example is like a fourth
grader
two girls are laughing and the kid
thinks that oh they're laughing at me
well the kid may be living in a very
violent household with a lot of arguing
and so he's not connecting it for him a
causal thing is they're laughing at me
so it must be
they're mad at me so he's not making the
connection from home to school but he
sees the two girls laughing at the joke
they told each other
so it has to be the reason for his
distress gotcha
um and then the last one is a plus b
equals y abstract reasoning and this is
where it can actually get kind of
theological and this is where i would
tell a parent
if they do have a faith-based community
to like let's talk to that person
okay if they don't they can just have
the conversation however
they feel comfortable but again to
practice that and
a really good rule of thumb and uh when
i'm prepping parents i'll say
i'll do a question that's kind of mean
like let's say like you know did you
hate my dad
and they're like why would he ask that
like well what would you say
and there's a stumble which is correct i
say you can say
i want to think about how to answer that
yep
and get can you know can we talk can we
talk about it later can we can mom buy
that get some time because mom also need
is
entitled to her time just like her son
there you go yeah i need to take some
space
mom's got bad news too right yes and so
to go back to your question so
for an egocentric like a kid and if
you're
like for kids who are not neurotypical
if you're conceived like
are they concrete or egos i'm not sure
go to the one below
right so egocentric so go to the lower
denominator and so
for an egocentric kid would say for
example
your dad shot like it'd be you know as
concrete as possible
if they know or your your like your dad
took a life
may be too abstract your dad hurt them
very badly
that he killed them then he killed
himself
and it had nothing to do with you and
then you just gotta
own that space and that weight and that
silence yeah right
yep and just silence is a is probably
the hardest part of these conversations
not what you say but what
when you when you take a break right for
a con for a concrete kid
it would sound very similar but i would
say probably the last statement that
i would say it had nothing to do with
you
do you feel safe right now yeah in this
room in our house
do you feel safe at school like
something that those really super
concrete things
that kids are might be worried about
like well is he going to hurt like
someone's going to hurt us now
right and for abstract kids what do you
think this will have like
are you worried about kids at high
school bringing this up for your buddy
um if so what kind of plan can we
generate to make sure you feel
like you're safe over there and you can
kind of go basically your uh
your zip code can enlarge uh depending
on the developmental stage
awesome but i still kind of like work
it's work off of that
i love not your fault concrete
and then abstract and again you can tell
the kid
we can check in tonight or tomorrow
morning if you have questions just let
mom know
so one last thing one last question here
um we'll keep it real quick
is um one of the most common
tools i give folks in this situation is
to write a letter
to the person who died by suicide
to write a letter to the person who died
in a car wreck
um and it's okay to be angry it's okay
to be frustrated but what i want to
gently do is to steer them towards
often when we experience when we our
loved ones die
in a in a traumatic way we get frozen on
their
current pain that they're currently
still hurting and there's something
about writing a letter to them letting
our feelings be heard and
moving them past they're not
experiencing that pain anymore right
yes um that lets uh us go
my question for you is does a 13 year
old with autism i i've had that backfire
on me when working with
clients with special needs does that
work with a kid with autism
so the short answer is it does it just
works kind of differently okay
um and so one of the things uh there's
some again wonderful resources out there
and i i i think that's a great first
step for a family
if they run into trouble or even if they
don't i usually advise them like
seek a therapist that's probably the
most uh evidence-based is trauma-focused
cbt
traumatic grief they can and it's
actually ts
trauma focus cbt is actually has data
for kids with autism and trauma
excellent good good okay yeah and i
think it actually is available in
in both in texas and also in your area
of the u.s
um but when we're doing that i would
also ask the parent
how the way your son processes
information do you think this would work
do you think a picture would be better
do you think he has to do something
physical there you go
um do like how does he not not just with
this but how does he process stressful
information like
he failed a test or um somebody like is
bullying him something that's not
obviously equivalent but something that
will trigger a stress response
how does he best process that uh so and
we're going to mirror that stress
response in this situation too and i'm
going to make it available to him
awesome
it's like well he he likes writing story
like so one kid
loved writing stories about uh marvel
superheroes he just write that he'd fill
up journals of them
that was how he coped with stressors and
so
when he you know when he was in foster
care we
you know that was kind of our go-to for
him when like it's something like well
the placement didn't work out or
court got extended or you got to go
testify we'd say hey let's
do you need a right buddy and then and
so he would
that would be his thing oh i had another
kid hated right he just
he wanted to do something more physical
more sensory and so like okay let's get
you in our motor room
you know we'll have you bounce around
there there you go conversation
um i like how you call it a motor room
that's where like my wife wishes i had a
motor room awesome
they're great yeah and so mom knows her
kid and that's what you keep telling
them is
you know your chip better than anyone on
the planet i love it and
and so how does he usually process
stressful information
awesome um well hey dude i gotta run you
are an absolute saint and so i'm
grateful for you for
giving up your time and at your hourly
rate that was probably about eleven
thousand dollars
just just awesome grateful for you i
wish
uh you'll come see me in nashville here
soon and i look forward to hanging out
but dude i'm i'm grateful for you dr
gomez thank you so much man
likewise like delany you take care over
there and keep doing the good work over
there okay i appreciate you man all
right
so hey to the listeners we're back and
um
i'm gonna take a quick break and what
i'm gonna do during this break is i'm
going to
interpret the mind of a brilliant trauma
psychologist
and how i can communicate that to
a hurting mom from my home state
we'll be right back
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important
your mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy
for you video chat phone or even
text chat counseling with licensed
therapists
that are going to help you become a
better version of yourself
help you get on the road to being well
go to betterhelp.com for 10
off your first month this is less
expensive than traditional therapy
and you're worth it betterhelp.com
deloney take care of yourself start
today
all right so now it's time to go to
hannah in
south texas hannah how in the world are
you
i'm doing well dr john how are you i'm
doing all right so i hear from
kelly that you have a lot going on in
your world
just just a bit man so
i have heard third hand second hand i
don't know i'm
removed but you and i have never spoken
and um
you know that you're part of a special
episode today where um i know
enough or a little bit about some of the
details that i
i called a friend of mine and a former
mentor mine or a current mentor mine
who's a
renowned trauma psychologist who works
with
traumatized kids and with autistic kids
and so
that seemed to fit your situation so
walk me through
what happened um
so uh my my son is um
he's been diagnosed with high
functioning autism
and adhd back in 2014.
so he was about six we were my
ex-husband and i were stationed overseas
um and they didn't have the i guess the
ability
to to diagnose him so he was a little
late on being diagnosed at about six
or six and a half okay um
and you know we we were working through
that my
ex-husband his dad and i divorced um we
separated in 2016
and the divorce was finalized in 2017.
okay um his dad moved back
to his hometown and i moved back to mine
so
there was a few hours difference but um
in terms of the commute but he was
he was a rock star so he was not an
ideal husband by any means
but he was a rock star dad and we've
gotten to a point
where we were back to being friends um
his dad would call me if you know if he
needed some help or some
[Music]
suggestions or guidance or just a
sounding board
and i would call him because i'm like
hey this is what we're experiencing
with jb what are your thoughts on this
um you all are co-parenting together
yeah absolutely and like i said we were
he was not an ideal husband but he was a
rock star dad
um and you know our our kiddo
just worshipped to the ground his dad
could do no wrong
um which is what kind of makes this
heart even harder
um so do me a favor do me a favor would
you take a big
deep breath and hold it for kind of one
two and three okay
take a deep breath hold it one
two three and let it out
okay all right so bring us to last
weekend
um so i
was at work um so i've gotten a
his dad had called him his normal
routine was to call him
um at bedtime and they talked for about
20 to 30 minutes
um and jv came down he's like i get to
see my dad
and i was like oh nice of your dad let
me know okay
um and so the next day
i was on the phone with one of my
girlfriends
kind of complaining about how he'd made
plans with our son but then
check to clear if we had anything going
on and that afternoon at work
i got a call from just to make things
easier
my mother-in-law so his dad's mom
um and it was just like ripping a
band-aid off she's like um
you know he's dead and i was like
what do you mean and i'm thinking it's a
car accident or
something's maybe happened at work
and she said that she'd just gotten off
the phone
with the detectives and he was dead
hit the girlfriend and and her child
were were dead as well
um they don't have all the details
there's an investigation
um but the the the gun
was was closest to jb's dad
um so i
called i've remarried um
and i called my husband who
is a police officer and you know he was
on shift and i said
i just got this call i don't know what
to do um
and he said he you know i'm getting off
the ship at this
so i avoided going home like i was
i needed to get all of like process it
and try and figure it out
um my husband came home and i was like
i'm still not ready um
can you take him out for burgers you
know just give me time and the whole
time
they were gone i was googling how do you
tell your son
you know that you're his dad's bed or
whatever
were you alone at this time no my so
my boss i called my boss and my boss was
like you're not driving
i'm coming back and i'm gonna take you
home my mom
my mom came to my house so she was with
me
um and it was still kind of one of those
um everything's in shock and i
remembered a few weeks back i'd listened
to an episode
where you would said get below the
child's eye level
um which isn't hard because my kid
powers over me anyway but
um i had him sit on the couch and i got
on the floor
and i said i talked to your grandma
today and your dad's dead
and he was just like what no no no no no
no
and i was like and i'm just sitting
there and i'm i'm choking up and holding
back tears i thought that
i've had all afternoon to rehearse this
i've got this down this is going to be
fine i can be clinical about it and it
it didn't work um the minute he started
saying no
i i broke down um can i tell you can i
interrupt real quick
yeah i'm so glad it wasn't clinical
yeah a great gift you gave yourself
and your son was a shared moment of
humanity
and sometimes as parents we want to make
that band-aid
we're going to tear that thing off
perfect in one one rip and
man um grief isn't like a band-aid
right and so i'm i'm actually relieved
that that
happened that way and that you all got
to share that however awful and
horrible that that moment will become a
stake in the ground for both of you all
to heal together
and so i'm glad that happened that way
um
so you broke down and i broke down
um jb started asking questions
and by this point there there had been
articles you know coming out and i was
starting to get
messages and phone calls and i just said
we don't know it was an accident that's
all i could
i i don't want to be the one to to take
that hero worship
away from him um and
i uh unfortunately we we were
we were good with it's an accident um
and then
uh one of the ways that jb kind of
self-suits
is he plays music and and things along
to the
to the lyrics so he had my phone and he
was doing
i guess karaoke pacing and stemming in
the backyard
and my mother god bless her sent an
article
um that said confirms see
sorry and so you know of course when you
post a link it kind of gives a little
blurb and the headline was
that and so you know he comes in and
he's like i thought you said this how
did it happen
what and i was just i was like i i don't
have details buddy
um that article i don't know what
grandma sent in
you know and so i'm now trying to trap
between a rock and a hard place of
i've never lied to our son
um i've been
so long as age-appropriate conversations
though
i've been very forthcoming and
everything
but now i'm just like what do i what do
i do
how do i answer these questions how do i
field these questions what if somebody
at school says something
yeah i'm i'm also having to defend him
to you know my family and my current
in-laws
because i'm getting the well it could
have been you
it could have been you and your son and
i'm like
if it couldn't have though like i mean i
would hope not
because while we were married
i mean he
he he loved with with such
such intensity and like
like he loved big but he also messed up
sure sure
oh um so together
so bring me to right now what does um
have you just avoided these
conversations with your son
no um so when he asks questions
i i give him the answers that i have
okay so everything that's coming forward
right now
is is what's in the news
um the detectives are still doing their
thing they've got to do different tests
and and all that stuff so it's still an
open investigation so until i have
until i have anything concrete i don't
want to answer questions
based on you know a local news article
i want to get my information from the
detectives um
in my experience detectives um
detectives will they'll say hey here's
where we're leaning
if you have those conversations they say
this is this is what it looks like
here's here's what i'm getting at um
there is the chance like so let's say
you're you
you hear that that set of facts and one
set of like there's a part of you that
would dream maybe he was murdered
right maybe that something happened to
him or maybe he came to protect
that little girl from this his crazy
girlfriend right
there's those kind of those things that
we dream about and then the detective
will say
i mean it's we're doing some forensics
just because that's what we do but
it's pretty clear that this is how this
played out right um
and what i don't want you to do is to
put off and put off and put off when
everyone around you
either believes they have a narrative or
is pretty sure that the narrative
they've got is
relatively right and then the
neighborhood kid
is the one who tells your son right does
that make sense it's right
yeah as has the detective hinted one way
this is what this looks like so
the last update that um and i'm getting
the information from
you know his his mom um the last
update that they had was um doorbell
footage showed
um his dad coming in to
the the house um and
there were immediately shots fired um
they did not
anticipate that they had time to defend
themselves
okay so it definitely it definitely
looks
the way that the articles are presenting
yeah so what i'm going to tell you
is if because there's media out
i would err on the side of telling my
son
here's what we at best best understand
at this moment
and not put that conversation off any
longer because what you don't want to do
is to plant any seeds at any point any
time
that mom's not going to tell me the
truth okay
and you mentioned something earlier that
i'm going to make sure you tattoo on
your heart
which is you will not be the one that
takes away his hero worship
that has already been done you will be
the person who volunteers to hold his
hand and walk through that pain with him
and being the person who talks to him
will not be and communicates what
actually happened to him is not the
person who took that away
okay okay that already has happened
there's a period at the end of that
sentence
what you what you can do is one of two
things you can
continue to pull away from him
relationally
or you can lean all in and say i'm going
to walk with you however hard this is
and so there's a big gap here that i
want to make sure you're processing
and i'm sure someone's told you this and
if they haven't
um it's okay to have your whole world
blown up
that your ex-husband has passed away you
can grieve him too even though you're
remarried and you love your new husband
and all that this guy's a part of you
you created life together you created
memories together y'all were overseas
together
it's okay to be devastated
okay yeah yeah and my husband has given
me
that space i mean i've i've laid on his
chest
bawling my eyes out like and and i told
him when i came home that day
i walked up to him and i said i need you
to understand i'm gonna cry
i'm gonna grieve i don't want you to
think that that means
that i i i love him
or miss him yeah yeah yeah i i didn't
want to
i wanted him to know that it wasn't out
of disrespect for him or our marriage or
the love that we have
but this was i was with him you know i
was with our son's dad
for a third of my life yeah he's a part
of you
he's part of that and he gave me this
perfectly imperfect child
and you know oh honey he's perfect baby
he's perfect he's perfect
he's like yes and
for everything and i've put my husband
through the ringer with all of my
you know crazy trees and all that good
jazz and he's just he's also a rock star
and he leaves it and good for him what a
stud
he went through um i had a box of
memories and keepsakes from my marriage
that were all of the photos
family photos and whatnot um and letters
from his dad from when he was deployed
and
um you know in all the different
trainings and whatnot that he'd written
to
jb that i i kept to make sure that he
would have those and when he turned 18 i
was going to say here you go or when he
was old enough to really
understand them i was going to hand them
over um
so when that night when we were
explaining it you know i went
out took him out to the garage and i
pulled everything out and we just had
letters and pictures and memorabilia
just kind of thrown all over the place
so he could see it
and my husband
took some of those pictures and he
brought him upstairs in his room
and he's like where do you want him and
he started putting pictures of his dad
and family photos and stuff in his room
because he's like
your dad's always gonna be there we love
you
we're here for you and we'll give you
the answers as we get them
awesome wow that's you're in a pretty
remarkable place and so
um and as a part of this call
i think kelly lets you know i met with
um
a mentor of mine like i said is an
expert in this and so
you'll be able to go back and we'll send
you a recording of
his his recommendations um he's
infinitely more brilliant than me i tend
to he's a very uh he's an exacto knife
and i tend to be a little bit of a
sledgehammer um but a couple of things
to keep in mind as you
move forward one is um
less is more be very clear your daddy
died
and he died by suicide best we know is
your daddy died by suicide
are you doing okay and that silence that
weight
of just saying that with a period at the
end of it um
do you know what suicide means let your
son tell you back what he understands
about that
dig into that um dr gomez told a story
about
an eight-year-old saying yeah that means
that they killed himself
you say yeah anything else and then the
child responded with yeah that means now
they're burning in hell
right and it was whoa let's stop right
there so we're going to have that
discussed right so
get let him speak to it and you
also know the things that um your son
uses so it may be that you're going to
play some music
the music that suits him um a number of
of young folks with autism have
very particular self-soothing behaviors
right and it may be that you set that up
for him and let him know hey we're gonna
have a hard conversation about
um we got some information about your
daddy that i'm gonna pass along to you
okay um always checking in do you feel
safe now
you are safe right now nobody's going to
hurt you not not here
um letting him know that he's okay now
and then moving to what i think will be
the hardest
the next hardest part here is um
and we don't know why but it appears
that
daddy killed your friend too and letting
that have appeared at the end of it
and that might ultimately be we're gonna
write a letter to dad
and we don't have answers to those
questions he didn't leave a note we
don't know why
we know that he really really loved you
and we know that he
was not well that he was really not well
at the end of this
at the end of his life and these these
moments are scary
and they are heartbreaking but i'm here
your stepdad's here
and we are going to rally around you and
this will be a really difficult season
for your family but i want you
your son to see you hurting to because
that's going to make him feel less crazy
give him permission to ask you questions
whenever they pop up
and they're going to come up at really
weird inopportune times
right i would strongly recommend um
dr gomez the he was one of the
founders of the tfcbt trauma focus
cognitive behavioral therapy
there are some great practitioners in
texas and i would look
for one in your local area or online
tf cbt is this is the acronym for it
and they will walk you through a very
stepwise program
you do this then we do this and then we
do this and we teach
young people behaviors on how to process
and feel that
trauma okay and i want you to make sure
you're getting the help you need through
this whole area
this whole season if somebody calls you
and says well that could have been
say we are done with this conversation
and if this continues i'm gonna hang up
on you
because it didn't and we're moving on is
that
hear me there draw a firm boundary there
nobody's gonna be planting these what if
garbage seeds in your mind that doesn't
benefit anybody
that's somebody else's drama that
they're not gonna bring to your house
right
um two or three years from now you may
exhale
to and look at your current husband and
say that could have been us
y'all can deal with that later that's
not a for right now
right um and then most importantly is
this
i want you and um again whether it's
writing a letter
drawing a picture i want you and your
son to
communicate a vision of where your
husband is now
and often when a kid experiences
somebody
adulthood too who's passed away
traumatically
we still remember them in the car wreck
in that moment of pain with the the shot
in their body and that rattles around
our hearts and minds and our souls
and there's something therapeutic about
doing the exercise of where is he now
he was hurting so bad he was sick he was
struggling so bad he died by suicide
but right now he's at peace right now
he's quiet and he's still he's not
hurting anymore
and there's something cathartic about
that and the big what if existential
questions
is he in heaven is he in hell that's
going to be for you and
the your particular faith leaders to
walk through together
um why why why did he do this why do
this that's going to be between you and
a professional therapist there's not
going to be a lot of great answers to
that
but i will tell you this um dr gomez
said this and i'll reiterate it
the fact that you have already met with
him
and already done the hard things that
your daddy died
um was so hard and it was such an olive
branch of trust to your
son you get to share that moment with
him to your
new husband your son's really really
lucky to have you hannah
it's really really lucky to have you and
i want you
to i want to thank you for blessing all
of us
very very very few of us will experience
what you experienced it's trauma on top
of trauma on top of trauma
and it's going to end up in the news and
your son's going to get harassed about
it at school
it's a big thing it's one of those
before and after moments for you and
your family and community
most of us won't experience that but all
of us
will experience hard conversations with
our kids all of us will experience
awkward grief when an old girlfriend or
an ex-husband dies we don't know how to
navigate that
all of us will be faced with
gut-wrenching conversations we don't
know what's next
i want to thank you for being brave and
honest and open with us and letting us
walk alongside you during this
for those listening man it's been a
heavy one it's been a heavy one
and i want to hearken back to circle
back to the beginning
with dr gomez um
i got two phds like
hundreds not thousands of people i've
walked through hard conversations with
heart series
i've i've done these death notifications
i've gone into a house
uh into houses similar to what um
hannah's ex-husband was involved with i
may have been there
and even then when you're dealing with
the pain or the hurt or the discomfort
or strong emotion of somebody else i
want to make sure i'm right
i want to make sure that i've crossed
all my t's and dotted all my eyes
and so i don't care how much schooling
you have how much experience you have
true professionals
stop and pause and call somebody
true professionals true people of
character and dignity
circle back and say hey i just want to
make sure i'm right on this deal
and i'm not saying i get it right all
the time i don't i know i screw up all
the time and i try to be honest when i
mess it up
but we live in a culture now we live in
a world now where
everybody's so quick to throw an opinion
on a fire everyone's so quick to
judge and to say it's because of this or
you did it because of that
and i just want to give you a glimpse of
behind closed doors that's not the way
most people that i know act
most practitioners call another
practitioner say i'm about to have a
hard conversation with a hurting mom
i need to make sure i'm walking through
this thing the right way or i've got
expertise on trauma i've got expertise
on
meeting with hurting families but i
don't have expertise in
hurting families with a young person
with autism how do i do that one right
walk me through things i need to know
about that um or somebody who's got
cancer or somebody who
um i i know what i strongly believe
about this political statement but i
haven't had this conversation with
someone who believes this way and so
walk me through what this person might
be feeling or experiencing
what i want everyone to do is slow down
in our lives
just slow down be a little more humble a
little slower to judge
a little a little quicker to be curious
a little quicker to ask one or two more
questions a little
slower to judge to shame to say oh i
know this one i know this one
i've been that guy man and you know what
you do you hurt people
with our kids ah that didn't hurt you're
fine maybe it did hurt
with our spouse we should do it like
this right where now she has to choose
between fighting me
or just going along with it right we're
so quick so quick so quick
i hope today's episode has given us all
one
moment of exhale
we're gonna hug our loved ones a little
bit tighter today
we're gonna bridge that gap between
those we love today because it's not
worth it man you never know
and two will be a little slower to judge
a little
a little quicker to reach out and make
sure we're on the right path i don't
care if you've done
something 100 times a thousand times one
more phone call doesn't hurt
you're gonna be okay being wrong you're
gonna be really gentle with people who
are hurting
and right now all of us all of us are
hurting
let's be a little slower and a little
gentler as i wrap up today's show
um man
i didn't mean for it to be this this on
the nose but
it's one of my favorite songs of all
time it's a slow quiet song by an
extraordinary songwriter named joe purdy
it's off the you can tell georgia album
was out in 2006.
and then in his song is ode to sad clown
and it goes like this
darling i've been down and out ever
since you left town
i ain't been the same no matter how hard
i try and sometimes we don't get to
choose the ones who wear these walking
shoes i'm just a poor blo
boy with the blues and no i ain't
nothing new
i'm gonna fill this whiskey cup and i'm
gonna pick this banjo up
i'm gonna play with the tragedies and
singing good time harmonies and
be right don't you let me down play that
one called sad clown
you know the ones about me i've been
thinking about leaving town
thanks for being with us today this has
been the dr john dolone show
[Music]
you